[Musique]
elle aime manier les chiffres éplucher
les projets de loi de finance mais avec
le temps la technicienne est devenue
plus politique au point de s'imposer
aujourd'hui comme une figure
incontournable de la droite à
[Musique]
l'Assemblée bonjour Véronique louvagi
bonjour Alors vous siégez à l'assemblée
de depuis 2012 maintenant sous les
couleurs du groupe les républicains et
il a fallu attendre votre 3oè mandat
pour que le Figaro vous consacre un
article avec pour titre Véronique
louvagi révélation de la droite à
l'Assemblée c'est pas un peu vexant pour
vous après plus de 10 ans qu'on vous
qualifie de révélation non pas du tout
je crois que on peut exister sans pour
autant faire la la une des médias
effectivement je suis une passionnée des
chiffres puisque c'est c'est mon métier
expert comptable j'aime aller au au bout
des choses et je pense qu'on prend du
temps aussi à comprendre les mécaniques
des finances publiques à comprendre les
mécaniques d'un projet de loi de
finances d'un budget de l'État et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui je les comprends
bien et d'une institution comme celle de
de l'Assemblée nationale aussi de oui
tout à fait parce que moi je j'ai voulu
en 2012 faire partie de la commission
des finances aussitôt quand je suis
arrivé ici et je n'ai pas pu
immédiatement parce qu'en 2012 euh donc
parmi les députés de de la droite il y
avait tous les anciens ministres un
grand nombre d'anciens ministres et
finalement l'acès à la commission des
finances leur été réservé donc j'ai dû
attendre un petit peu pour accéder à la
commission fin en gros les les barons de
la droite truster les places occuper la
première ligne vous avez V oui oui
c'était ça parce que il y avait je
dirais une certaine envie en tout cas
une certaine fierté d'être à la
commission des finances un certain
prestige et j'ai dû attendre 2014 où là
françois Barouin qui faisait partie de
la commission des finances et est parti
au Sénat et donc là il y a une place et
hop comme je suivais ça comme le lait
sur le feu j'ai pu accéder à la
commission des finances alors ce terme
de révélation employé par le Le Figaro
il peut surprendre et en même temps dans
cette assemblée sans majorité absolu
vous avez pris une dimension nouvelle
que ce soit sur la remise sur les prix
du carburant au début de la législature
ou sur la réforme des retraites c'est
vous avec Olivier marlex qui esttes allé
discuter négocier en tout cas à Matignon
avec ellisabeth borne ou à Bercy avec
Bruno Le Maire c'est un un nouveau rôle
ce sont de nouvelles responsabilités qui
vous ont plu c'est oui effectivement sur
les deux mandats précédents la situation
était complètement différente là nous
retrouvons avec un paysage
politique particulier à l'Assemblée
nationale et et donc le gouvernement
essaie de discuter avec un certain
nombre de groupes dont le groupe les les
républicains et Olivier marlex m'a
associé pour tout ce qui concernait les
finances et m'a laissé finalement un
petit peu maître pour discuter sur le
premier projet de loi de finance
rectificatif concernait le pouvoir
d'achat
et je me suis trouvé à discuter donc
avec la première ministre en premier
lieu et ensuite avec Bruno Le Maire lors
du débat lors de l'examen de ces textes
et c'est vrai que c'était assez inédit à
la fois dans la forme parce que nous
connaissions pas et et puis moi me
retrouvé ici je dirais voilà c'était un
peu particulier mais ça vous a ça vous a
plu vous avez pris du plaisir à vous
retrouver comme ça en première ligne au
cœur du pouvoir un peu dire que j'ai
retrouvé du plaisir à être en première
ligne non mais j'ai trouvé beaucoup de
satisfaction à à pouvoir être active
finalement et et à pouvoir je dirais
avoir les mains dans le camboui être
proche pour pour discuter euh être le
relais de de mon groupe et j'ai essayé
de le faire au mieux et et je me
souviens que quand un jour le le
ministre m'a demandé de de le retrouver
à l'Assemblée nationale en m'indiquant
nous nous retrouvons au bureau des
ministres à l'Assemblée nationale
j'ignoré un bureau des ministres à
l'Assemblée j'ignorais après 10 ans de
présence ici qu'il y avait un bureau des
ministres à l'Assemblée c'est dire que
ça n'était pas pas du tout
habituel ben j'ai oui j'ai demandé à
Olivier marleex donc où était ce bureau
c'est lui qui me l'a indiqué parce que
finalement il n'y avait que les députés
qui étaient là au moment où il
appartenaient à la majorité donc pas
beaucoup à à droite qui connaissaiit
l'existence de ce bureau des ministres
ou des personnes qui étaient un peu plus
proches des je dirais de de la MAN
politique et de l'organisation quoi sur
les retraite vous avez trouvé un
compromis avec le gouvernement sauf
qu'une partie des députés LR a quand
même refusé de V cette réforme alors que
vous étiez engagé he auprès d'Élisabeth
borne vous aviez un peu donné votre
parole au nom du groupe les républicains
vous l'avez vécu comme un échec
personnel ça ou non je crois que ce
n'est pas un échec
personnel nous avons en fait une
nouvelle méthode à construire au niveau
de de l'Assemblée nationale et et nous
nous apprenons je crois que l'exécutif
aussi le gouvernement apprend et et nous
les groupe de de de l'opposition nous
apprenons moi moi je veux construire
voilà nous avons ici 5 ans le besoin le
pays a besoin de nous euh il faut que
nous puissions avancer donc je ne
renonce aucunement à mes convictions euh
parce que c'est c'est c'est important je
le porte de manière très très forte mais
je crois que quand quelque chose est
bien il faut pouvoir avancer alors il
faut que nous tirons des enseignements
de nos erreurs de nos échecs parce que
il faut reconnaître que nous
sortons fctionn non ça n'a pas
fonctionné nous en sortons affaiblis euh
et donc il faut rebondir mais il faut
tirer des forces de ces échecs je je
crois que c'est ce que nous essayons de
faire aujourd'hui avec Olivier marlex et
Eric cotti alors vous êtes l'une des
députés les plus assidus dans dans
l'hémicycle j'ai lu qu'à plusieurs
reprises vous vous êtes retrouvé à
siéger toute seule sur les bans de la
droite au point que vos adversaires ont
rebaptisé votre groupe LR du nom de vos
initiales VL pour Véronique louvagie
c'est vrai ça c'est oui c'est vrai parce
que bon l'examen d'un projet de loi de
finance c'est c'est quelque chose qui
dure assez longtemps he vous avez vous
voit sur cette image vous
êtes oui c'est c'est vous avez des
séances qui qui commence le lundi à 16h
et qui se term quelquefois le samedi ou
le dimanche euh donc effectivement je me
suis retrouvé quelquefois seul et et
donc bon voilà un petit peu par sourire
par rire les les députés des autres
groupe M appelé le groupe vlo et
qu'est-ce qui vous fait tenir comme ça
dans des séances de nuit parfois jusqu'à
1h du matin à défendre des amendements
qui sont d'ailleurs pas forcément les
votres mais ceux de vos collègues du
groupe LR des amendements qui pour la
plupart sont rejetés je je pense que
j'ai j'ai un peu le sens de de de la
perfection en tout cas le sens de
l'engagement c'estàd que quand je
m'engage là je me suis engagé au nom du
groupe des députés les républicains pour
sur cette question du projet de loi de
finances et et donc je je vais jusqu'au
bout en tout cas j'y prends je je suis
revenu plusieurs fois les dimanches
notamment pour être l'orateur de group
républicain au moment des des
discussions générales sur l'émotion de
censure en tout cas je suis très
attachée à ça parce que j'ai j'ai j'ai
j'ai une valeur très importante sur la
notion d'engagement pour moi c'est
quelque chose de fort alors vous faites
partie du petit club des spécialistes
des finances publiques à l'Assemblée
vous avez même été élu vice-président de
la commission des finances en général
les finances publiques ça fait pas
forcément rêver les députés c'est
souvent jugé très technique un peu
rébarbatif qu'est-ce qui vous plaît dans
cette matière c'est c'est votre passé
d'expert comptable qui vous a attiré
vers ça ou vous savez quand on est
expert comptable on est quand même
proche des des chiffres on aime les
chiffres sinon je pense que ça sera une
catastrophe voilà donc on a une
voilà je j'ai j'ai beaucoup appris aussi
avec Gilles carz à partir de 2014 j'ai
beaucoup aimé présent oui tout à fait un
spécialiste des des finances publiques
et et véritablement les finances
publiques c'est la déclinaison de toutes
les politiques publques qui parlent au
quotidien au français donc sur la
question de la santé de l'éducation
nationale du logement je pense qu'au
travers les chiffres derrière je dirais
il y a des orientations des prismes qui
concernent tous les Français et moi je
veux modifier je veux améliorer un
certain nombre de points qui concerern
la vie des Français finalement c'est
c'est mon objectif et d' d'où cette
importance des des comptes publics alors
votre premier engagement politique il
remonte à 1983 vous aviez 22 ans à
l'époque je crois vous avez été élu
conseillère municipal d'un petit village
dans l'heure c'est là où vous habitiez à
l'époque on vous voit d'ailleurs en
photo là à cette époque dans une course
de sac c'est la jeune conseillère
municipale sauf qu'ensuite plus rien
jusqu'aux années 2000 pourquoi
alors j'ai été effectivement conseillère
municipal sur un mandat qui est qui a
duré 6 ans et et et ensuite je me suis
trouvé enfin juste avant de de finir ce
mandat j'ai eu de deux enfants
j'attendais un 3è j'ai tris enfants en 3
ans et je me suis engagé aussi dans une
activité d'expert comptable voilà où
j'ai créé mon cabinet d'expertise
comptable donc j'avais beaucoup
d'engagement à la fois familiaux à la
fois professionnel et et ayant déménagé
je n'avais plus aucun attrait dans dans
ce cette commune où j'avais été élu donc
du coup je me suis retrouvée je dirais
et à m'occuper de mes enfants et
m'occuper de mon cabinet d'expertise
comptable où j'ai j'y ai passé beaucoup
de temps j'ai trouvé beaucoup de plaisir
et je me suis beaucoup engagé aussi et
alors la la politique est revenue dans
votre vie et tout s'est accéléré pour
vous à partir de 2010 en 3 ans vous avez
été élu conseillère régional conseillère
départemental puis député en
2012 pour ce qui est des législatives
vous y êtes allé contre la vie de vos
enfants
et de votre mari oui c'est vra
effectivement on a fait un petit conseil
de famille avec mon époux et et mes
trois enfants et et tous les qure m'ont
dit non il ne faut pas que tu y ailles
c'est trop et donc je les ai laissé
parler ça ça duré une petite heure et à
la fin je leur a dit j'irai vous y êtes
allé donc vous avez vous avez été élu
vous en êtes donc je le disais
aujourd'hui à votre trè mandat et alors
vous dites que le plus dur c'est pas la
première élection c'est la deuxème oui
pourquoi alors la première élection vous
vous n'êtes pas élu je dirais sur un
bilan euh vous vous bénéficiez du du je
dirais du du de la méconnaissance oui de
de de votre personne et donc on peut
faire confiance la deuxième vous êtes
élu euh sur un bilan sur un passé avec
quelquefois des prises de position qui
ne correspondent pas forcément euh à à
ce qu'attendent les citoyens donc je je
dirais que c'est beaucoup plus difficile
parce que euh vous n'avez plus le
bénéfice du doute et je crois que la je
le dis d'ailleurs à à tous mes collègues
hein la la 2uxè élection pour moi c'est
la plus difficile localement vous avez
mis en place un un dispositif assez
original de démocratie participative
vous appelez ça les conseils de
circonscription ça fonctionne comment
expliquez-nous alors j'ai voulu
effectivement mettre enfin faire en
sorte que ce ce fussé qui existe entre
les citoyens et et le
député ou les élus d'une manière
générale bon qu'on qu'on fasse en sorte
qu'il soit moins important et donc j'ai
créé un un groupe avec 70 personnes donc
je fais des appels à candidature des
personnes ont répondu du euh nous avons
ensuite fait une sélection je fais une
sélection en fonction notamment des âges
pour avoir autant de femmes que d'hommes
de répartition aussi sur la la
circonscription de profil et et ces
personnes se réunissent régulièrement en
conseil de circonscription avec une
déclinaison en commission il y a six
commissions économie euh et vous les
faites traver sur des sur des sujets
comme ça voilà là nous avons travaillé
sur la fin de vie et il vote pas pas
toujours mais sur la le dernier conseil
de circonscription je leur ai fait voter
et alors ces votes vous en faites quoi
après alors moi je je je je ça ne
m'engage pas parce que je je suis libre
de mes convictions mais mais en revanche
j' j'en ça m'alimente et je crois que
c'est très important en tout cas que
nous nous ayons un point sur de
discernement du du terrain des remontées
du terrain je crois que ça c'est c'est
fort alors on va passer à notre quiz à
présent vous allez devoir compléter les
phrases que je vais vous proposer
d'accord c'est parti à ceux qui disent
que je pourrais allié Emmanuel Macron
pas possible pas possible parce que
votre nom circule parfois comme ça oui
mais laissez les noms
circuler euh la meilleure blague entre
expert comptbl alors vous savez les
experts comptables on est assez sérieux
on est basé un peu sur le le réel
puisque finalement on constate la
réalité à travers des bilans à compte de
résultats et souvent on se dit à quoi
servent les économistes et et notre
blague c'est de dire que heureusement
qu'ils sont là pour que nous puissions
rire d'eux parce que les économistes ils
partent dans des oui et puis nous les
les
comptables les comptables nous ne sommes
pas forcément des des des gens très
drôles en général nous ne sommes pas
perçus comme ça quand je ne serai plus
député je pourrais enfin pouponner
auprès de mes petits enfants j'ai 10
petits enfants et ça sera un vrai
bonheur oui et là c'est compliqué avec
votre engagement ou oui mais vous savez
que je le disais à mes collègues députés
je leur disais faites comme moi ayez 10
petits enfants il y aura plus de
problème de réforme des
retraites la
solution bon merci beaucoup Véronique
louvagi d'être venue dans la politique
et moi merci à vous
[Musique]
merci